SEAN ROBINSON:
There's an exercise
we do very early in the
semester, where we hand out
to the students a bunch
of small aluminum cuboids.
They're long rectangles, a
few centimeters on each side.
And then we hand them a
very cheap plastic ruler,
a $0.16 ruler from an
office supply store.
The cubes are machined
to very high precision
to be identical to each other.
The rulers are very inexpensive.
And we have them--
we say, go measure
the length, width, and
height of this cuboid.
Don't tell anybody
what you measured.
But just write down
your best measurement,
and your best estimate
of the uncertainty
on that measurement,
and along with that,
come up with a
measure of the volume.
Maybe, you measure
the volume, say,
by multiplying x times y
times z, and an estimate
of the uncertainty on that.
And everybody thinks this
is a very silly exercise.
It's so easy.
This is something you would
do in elementary school.
Here we are in our third year
as physics majors at MIT.
Why are we wasting
our time on this?
But if it's so easy, then when
we flip around the white board
and show everybody all
each other's answers,
if it's so easy, why
are the answers all so
different from each other?
That is a big moment
of cognitive dissonance
for the students.
And then we spend the next,
say, 15 to 45 minutes,
really, just having a very
active discussion about, what
did these error bars
that you reported
to us as your uncertainty
on the volume,
what does that really mean?
Why is this person's
error bar so small?
Why is this person's so large?
Let's look at the spread between
all of the different people's
numbers and compare it to what
you reported as uncertainty.
Are these things consistent?
Are these inconsistent?
For the instructor who's
leading that discussion,
that's somewhat of a
challenge because he's
about to see some numbers,
and lead a discussion on it,
which he's never seen before.
Inevitably, all of our
instructors get up to the plate
and do a good job at that.
But it's remarkable, how much
comes from this very simple
little exercise.
The students learn a lot
about random errors, which
are statistical
errors, which are
something you can learn from a
mathematics book on statistics.
You learn a lot about
systematic errors, which
are very, very difficult,
and no one really
has a good understanding of.
But it all comes up in
this very simple exercise
that everybody
learns a lot from.
In general, it's
always a challenge
for a teacher to run
a group discussion
and get the students to actually
participate in that discussion,
right?
In general, that's
always something
that's tricky as a teacher.
People want to sit back,
and be quiet, and just hear
what other people have to say.
It's always a challenge.
For this exercise,
which is usually
done at the end of
a three hour session
where they've been
measuring other things,
and then you flip
around the board
and show them the list of
numbers, people are surprised.
This is something-- this is
numbers they just measured.
And they're surprised what they
see that everybody else did.
It is not hard at all
to get people talking
and really get them
all participating
in that conversation.